okay
are you ready
hello i'm johnny knoxville and we're
going to break down some iconic scenes
from jackass
[Music]
we're going to do for you i was partying
last night with some frat guys i passed
out i must have fallen down and broken
something because i haven't been able to
walk right since
we're gonna take x right now okay to be
sure
oh
this is comfy hold your breath
well the hardest thing to do is define
talent for that bit because it was
written for
somebody and then somebody didn't want
to let their dad down and so we had to
find somebody else and
luckily ryan was there he's like this
idea is too good man find somebody to do
it and if nobody else will do it i'll do
it that's all i heard is i'll do it
[Music]
whose idea was it to put the toy car in
a condom in order to get it up ryan's
butt that's a good idea it was yeah i
don't know because that that was the
good way to pull it out even though we
didn't know what was gonna happen we did
not know we were warned by uh multiple
safety people that getting up there is
not the problem getting to come out
exactly
but some genius decide figured out in
our group right well luckily good old
ryan was loosey-goosey
i have no idea
that's not part of you
that's something extra i would have
known if i ate that
no you you wouldn't be able to swap that
oh man ryan is so funny like he's so
naturally funny that's one of the things
i missed so much not worried about
looking cool like just
like for that just taking one for the
team especially at that time now you
know i think everyone's gone done so
much stuff where they they're not
worried about their pride that's true
you got to put it in the context of when
we said at the time
yeah yeah it was a pretty radical idea
at the time oh yeah
he was also very comedically grumpy too
which was great yeah yeah and again the
improv he did was just just
making up the story on the fly of what
happened to the nice doctor who is
really only concerned about
his safety and his moral dilemma
[Laughter]
[Music]
god
[Applause]
[Music]
damn these balls are strong
already existed and we were doing the
the yak charge which i had seen in the
cartoon and and did gary lefew suggest
bring up the torah tonight
we didn't know about this and then we
saw footage of it and it seemed like a
good idea based on the footage we saw
yeah and you know what it did turn out
to be a good idea yeah i i'm really
scared of bulls but i was like i got to
be a part of this right
not me
not me man the craziest thing about that
and you don't see it in the way
it's edited is that
we got it like he got drilled into the
knoxville got drilled and crushed by the
the bull and he came out pretty
unscathed i mean he's banged up pretty
hard
and we're talking and
knoxville's asking me hey did we get
that i'm like yes we got it like i'm not
sure i'm like i don't know if we got it
it's like the camera's still in place
i'm like yes but we got it and he's like
okay and then he just jumped back in the
ring and the bullet he hadn't wrangled
that bull yet and he jumped back on the
teeter-totter and then the thing really
went to town
we went into the worst place yeah i
don't i do remember my leg went down in
but you got stuck right there and it was
just pressing i thought you're gonna
break your face really hit my leg then
it would have been just a right or a
90-degree break
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
you ever been run over by a car
and then re-run over by the car
that's what it kind of feels like
you ready
well stevo wanted to be pushed off a
bridge in the port-a-potty right but but
jeff
said why don't you go up yeah it was
initially supposed to fall off of a
bridge and then they changed it was
gonna be a bridge on a bungee so it was
gonna bounce up and down right and it
was just absolutely genius to change it
to where it shoots up because then the
poo comes out at the apex of the
launch i mean it's just so epic the
problem was
is that osha
which is like the regulatory safety
stuff
had a rule against like being covered in
human feces
so they actually found a company which
sells dog poo and as much dog poo as you
want and the name of that company was we
do do do
and they bought enough dog poo to fill
up a porta potty the best thing about
that bit though is that stevo was so
concerned about safety he made sure he
had the goggles on
he got the earplugs he pinched his nose
he had it all figured out to where
nothing no poo is getting on him it's
gonna just pass over him and then the
first thing he does as soon as that poo
starts coming up is he just screams
opens his mouth
i mean you can just watch at least a big
gulp worth of just
dog and some human cameraman
uh knoxville said when we played the
footage back he said it's a good thing
your mouth was so wide open steve
otherwise that poo might have hit you in
the face
you can almost smell that stunt though
on even watching it on camera oh my god
because it was so bad that
poop we had was so rancid like when it
oh it went up and then it shook and all
this rain but that's what we didn't
anticipate
and we just got covered it was like a
torrential downpour wow
yeah it kind of turned into a lard ass
scene from stand by me
it was one of the greatest things i've
ever seen and the best is like he's in
this five-point harness that he has no
idea how to get out of it so he's
trapped in this
container and just waiting and luckily
ryan was the only one who knew how to
undo the damn thing
and then you just came after everybody
you could
right i just googled the hardest punch
ever recorded his punch is the
equivalent of being hit by a foreign
escort at top speed why you don't need
to read that now
[Laughter]
francis nganu was amazing he was so fun
to shoot with
and god he literally hits like a truck
right he is the most powerful punch ever
recorded in human history
the guinness world record
and i'm a big ufc fan so when i found
out that francis singhani was coming to
the set to punch
aaron in the nuts i i i wanted to
volunteer i actually said oh dude let me
get this bit let me get that let me have
francis punch me
and in hindsight i'm so glad that i
didn't step into that because
it wasn't just francis and ganu i mean
it was
test after test after test and by the
time that was done i could not have been
more grateful that i was not the one
doing the concept you might have been
smarter about some of the like for some
reason we left it up to aaron to pick
the cups and the jocks
and i was thinking he's like
blown out jocks up so the thing was kind
of dangling and wearing them
i picked a super flexible one for the
pogo stick yeah so that like let it just
slip up and pinch his
scrotum to the ground
like aaron was the perfect guy for that
like that bit was written for knoxville
it was supposed to be knoxville redoing
the cup test but uh he had a hernia
surgery right before we started shooting
so the doctor said no way can you
and so that one got passed and aaron was
the natural backstop that it landed at
gotta be over dude i think we're all the
way finished we're through
stick a fork in it
i don't know that we've accomplished
everything we've set out to do i don't
even think that was a thought was it
yeah i don't think we set out to do
anything aside from making each other
laugh there's no grand plan in this it's
an ongoing experience of having fun yeah
with your friends right
but then again the other on the other
hand
we could never have imagined that we
would have accomplished what we did and
when i found out that knoxville wanted
to make a fourth movie i thought it was
really scary to kind of jeopardize
everything that we had built everything
that we had gotten away with and we
recklessly rolled the dice again we got
lucky again and
we made this movie that's just so epic
that
it's really a good spot to be in we made
our own luck stephen
but yeah i i think yeah accomplish what
we meant to accomplish with making a
movie that will make people laugh
and really happy
what did you guys do to eric
i also prepare prepare to fail
you still got those million dollar teeth
that's for sure
you